You probably remember when those Danish cartoons of the prophet Mohammed caused so much anger in the Muslim world. Violent protests over Europe and the Middle East, flags were burned, Danish products pulled off shelves. It's blasphemy to depict the prophet at all. Many American newspapers would not reprint the Danish cartoons. And is this true for you? I am not actually sure I've ever seen any kind of picture of the prophet Mohammed, ever.
你可能还记得，当那些丹麦报纸刊登的穆罕默德先知漫画在穆斯林世界引发巨大愤怒时的情况。欧洲和中东爆发了暴力抗议，旗帜被焚烧，丹麦产品被下架。描绘先知形象被视为亵渎。许多美国报纸拒绝转载这些丹麦漫画。你也是这样吗？其实我不确定自己是否曾见过任何关于穆罕默德先知的画像，一次都没有。
Well with that in mind, it's kind of interesting to hear that there is a place in this country where you can see an image of Mohammed right now. There's actually a sculpture of Mohammed on display in Washington, DC. And not in some crackpot salon. This is actually in a US government building. And it's not just any US government building. It's the Supreme Court building. And it's not just any room in the Supreme Court building. It's actually in the room where the justices hear cases. You're a US Supreme Court Justice, you look up and to the right from the bench, and there's Mohammed.
考虑到这一点，听到这个国家竟然有一个地方现在就能看到穆罕默德的画像，感觉挺有意思。华盛顿特区实际上确实陈列着一座穆罕默德的雕塑。而且它不在什么古怪的沙龙里，而是在一座美国政府大楼里。不仅如此，它还是最高法院大楼。而且不仅是在最高法院大楼的随便哪个房间，它实际上就在大法官们听取案件的法庭里。如果你是美国最高法院大法官，从法官席抬头向右看，就能看到穆罕默德。
And hearing this, perhaps right now you're asking yourself the exact same question that Ibrahim Hooper had when he first heard about this.
听到这里，也许你此刻正在问自己一个问题，这正是易卜拉欣·胡珀第一次听说这件事时的疑问。
Why would they have an image of the prophet Mohammed in the Supreme Court?
为什么他们要在最高法院里放置一幅穆罕默德先知的画像？
Unlike you, however, it is Ibrahim Hooper's job to get to the bottom of this kind of thing. Hooper, I should tell you, seems like an unusually cheerful man to have the job that he has. Every single day he goes off to work in an office with the not so simple mission of explaining the Muslim perspective to non-Muslims.
然而，与你不同，易卜拉欣·胡珀的工作就是要把这类事情查个水落石出。我得说，胡珀作为一个从事这项工作的人，显得出奇地乐观。他每天去办公室工作，肩负着一个并不简单的使命：向非穆斯林解释穆斯林的观点。
I'm spokesman or communications director for the Council on American-Islamic Relations.
我是美国伊斯兰关系委员会的发言人兼通讯主任。
And it was in this job that back in 1996, he first heard about this sculpture. And he looked into it.
正是因为这份工作，他在1996年首次听说了这座雕塑。于是他进行了调查。
What you see when you go in to the Supreme Court is there's a series of sculptures around the top of the main room. And one of them is of the prophet Mohammed. And he is shown with a sword in one hand and a Koran in the other.
当你走进最高法院时，你会看到主厅上方有一系列雕塑。其中之一就是穆罕默德先知。他被描绘成一手持剑，一手拿着《古兰经》。
He's actually one of 18 figures, all of them lawgivers throughout the ages including Moses and Solomon, Hammurabi the King of Babylon, King John of England whose seal is actually on the Magna Carta, Augustus Caesar who was the first emperor of Rome. You have Charlemagne, Confucius, Napoleon, basically all of them lined up in a row like it's a small, small world at Disneyland but for lawyers, OK?
他实际上是18位人物之一，这些人都是历代的立法者，包括摩西、所罗门、巴比伦王汉谟拉比、英国国王约翰（其印章就在《大宪章》上）、罗马第一位皇帝奥古斯塔斯·凯撒。还有查理曼大帝、孔子、拿破仑，基本上他们一字排开，就像迪士尼乐园里的“小小世界”，只不过是为律师准备的，明白吗？
And they tell us it was designed to pay tribute to these people, including the prophet Mohammed. And we don't disagree with that.
他们告诉我们，这个设计的初衷是为了向这些人致敬，包括穆罕默德先知。我们对此并不反对。
Now it's my understanding this has been there since the '30s.
据我了解，这个雕塑从30年代就在那里了。
Yeah, and we almost hated to bring it up to them of this. If they really think it's there to honor them, it's like well what else are these guys going to complain about?
是的，我们其实很不愿向他们提起这件事。如果他们真的认为这是为了向他们致敬，那这些人还有什么好抱怨的呢？
Ibrahim says that the problem from a Muslim perspective was not just that they depicted the prophet Mohammed in this sculpture.
易卜拉欣说，从穆斯林的视角来看，问题不仅仅在于他们塑造了穆罕默德先知。
But in this case in particular, you've got a somewhat stereotypical representation in that it has the sword and the Koran, which is often-- people make the stereotype of Islam was spread with camel riding Muslims going across the desert with a sword in one hand and the Koran in the other. So that in itself, along with the visual representation of the prophet, is a problem for Muslims.
特别是在这个案例中，这是一个带有某种刻板印象的形象，因为它拿着剑和《古兰经》，这通常会让人联想到关于伊斯兰教传播的刻板印象：骑着骆驼的穆斯林横穿沙漠，一手拿着剑，一手拿着《古兰经》。所以，单凭这一点，再加上对先知的视觉描绘，对穆斯林来说就是一个问题。
So, on behalf of his organization and American Muslims, Ibrahim wrote a letter to the Supreme Court. And he met with the Supreme Court staff in what he says was a very amicable meeting. And before long, he got an answer about the sculpture and a letter from then Chief Justice Rehnquist.
因此，代表他的组织和美国穆斯林，易卜拉欣写信给了最高法院。他与最高法院的工作人员会面，他说那是一次非常友好的会谈。不久之后，他得到了关于雕塑的回应，那是时任首席大法官伦奎斯特的一封信。
They came back saying basically that because it was designed to honor the prophet, that it would not be changed. But that the literature describing-- it's called the North Wall Frieze-- would be changed to reflect some of the criticism.
他们的回复基本上是说，因为这是为了纪念先知而设计的，所以不会改变。但描述它的文字说明——被称为“北墙楣饰”——将会被修改，以反映一些批评意见。
"Altering the stone carving," the Chief Justice wrote, would quote "impair the artistic integrity of the whole." And as to the fact that Mohammed was shown with a sword, Rehnquist said, quote, "I would point out that swords are used throughout the Court's architecture as a symbol of justice. Nearly a dozen swords appear in the courtroom friezes alone." And so, with that, the statue stays.
首席大法官写道：“改动石雕将会损害整体的艺术完整性。”关于穆罕默德手持宝剑这一点，伦奎斯特说：“我想指出，在法院的建筑中，剑一直被用作正义的象征。仅在法庭的楣饰中就出现了近十二把剑。”于是，雕像被保留了下来。
But the official Supreme Court information sheet about it says, quote, "The figure above is a well-intentioned attempt by the sculptor to honor Mohammed and it bears no resemblance to Mohammed." And then it says, "Muslims generally have a strong aversion to sculptured or pictured representations of their prophet." That is, we know you are offended, and we acknowledge that. Now sit down.
但最高法院关于它的官方信息单上写道：“上方的形象是雕塑家旨在向穆罕默德致敬的一次善意的尝试，它与穆罕默德本人毫无相似之处。”接着又写道：“穆斯林通常对塑造或描绘先知的形象有强烈的抵触情绪。”换句话说，我们知道你们被冒犯了，我们也承认这一点。现在请坐下。
A bit disappointing, but at least we did what we needed to do.
有点令人失望，但至少我们做了我们该做的事。
I have to say, the moral of the story is sort of dispiriting. It's one of these moments where people are trying to be inclusive. And even then, they screw it up.
我不得不说，这个故事的教训有点令人沮丧。这是人们试图表现包容的时刻之一。即便如此，他们还是搞砸了。
Yeah, and it's kind of a situation where people aren't quite understanding each other's perspective. We would hope that people would understand why we would raise objections about this portrayal. But I have the feeling that people on the other side are scratching their heads and going, you can't please them. We thought we were doing a good thing by putting in an image of the prophet Mohammed and still they don't like it.
是的，这种情况反映出人们并没有完全理解对方的视角。我们希望人们能理解我们为什么要对这种描绘提出异议。但我感觉对方阵营的人可能会摸不着头脑，心想：真是难以满足。我们以为通过放置穆罕默德先知的画像是在做一件好事，可他们还是不喜欢。
And how typical is this kind of thing?
这类事情有多典型呢？
Well it seems to be getting worse as we go along. We had the recent situation where we had the imams praying in an airport in Minnesota. And that seemed to freak people out. And then they were taken off the plane. And from our perspective, who could object to somebody praying? But from other people's perspectives, they say, well they prayed before they crashed the planes into the World Trade Centers.
看来这种情况正在变得越来越糟。最近发生了伊玛目在明尼苏达州机场祈祷的事情。这似乎让人们感到恐慌。然后他们被带下了飞机。从我们的角度来看，谁会反对别人祈祷呢？但从其他人的角度来看，他们会说，他们在大楼倒塌撞向世贸中心之前也祈祷过。
Which brings us to today's program, stories of Muslims and non-Muslims shouting across a divide, trying to communicate with each other and not always getting their point across. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Act One of today's show, forget about the problems of presidents and diplomats have being understood by each other. Why would it be so hard for Muslims and non-Muslims to get along in the fourth grade.
这引出了今天的节目，讲述穆斯林和非穆斯林隔着鸿沟大声疾呼，试图沟通却总是无法传达彼此想法的故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的第一幕，别提总统和外交官们难以相互理解的问题了。为什么穆斯林和非穆斯林在四年级就这么难相处呢？
Act Two, America the Ad Campaign. In that act, Shalom Auslander explains the difficulties of selling brand America to the Arab world, which he experienced in his job at a big ad agency. Stay with us.
第二幕，美国广告活动。在这一幕中，沙洛姆·奥斯兰德将解释向阿拉伯世界推销“美国品牌”的困难，这是他在一家大型广告公司工作时的亲身经历。请继续收听。
Act One, Which One of These is Not Like the Others? This is partly a story about Muslims and non-Muslims not seeing eye to eye. But it's also about how that kind of dispute can affect a family. And effect it in a really big way, a surprisingly large way. Alix Spiegel tells what happened.
第一幕，“哪一个与众不同？”这部分讲述的是穆斯林和非穆斯林无法达成共识的故事。但它也关于这种争端如何影响一个家庭，而且是以一种非常巨大的、令人惊讶的程度影响。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔讲述了发生的事情。
This sad story begins with a happy one, a love story set in a location not usually associated with love stories, the West Bank. It was there that Serry met her husband, a man with a wonderful sense of humor who, like Serry, felt strongly about his Islamic faith. Now because they were observant Muslims, the couple didn't date in the traditional American way. Instead, they met exclusively in the presence of family, talked, exchange philosophies. Serry was, is, an American, born and bred. But these restrictions didn't bother her, didn't faze her at all.
这个悲伤的故事始于一个快乐的爱情故事，地点不在通常与爱情故事联系在一起的西岸。塞里就是在那里遇见了她的丈夫，一个充满幽默感，并且像塞里一样坚定信仰伊斯兰教的男人。由于他们是虔诚的穆斯林，这对夫妻并没有像传统美国人那样约会。相反，他们只在有家人在场时见面，交谈并交流哲学观点。塞里是地地道道的美国人，但在这些限制面前，她一点也不介意，一点也不受影响。
I pretty much knew this was the person I wanted to have children with. I knew he was a really decent, to the core kind of guy. And it really didn't take long for us to realize, we were pretty much soul mates.
我基本上知道这就是我想一起生儿育女的人。我知道他从骨子里就是一个真正正派的人。我们没过多久就意识到，我们是灵魂伴侣。
So there really was no question that they would get married. No question that they would spend the rest of their lives together. The only real question was where to raise their family. On this point, Serry felt pretty strongly. When they were getting to know each other, her husband had shared horror stories about his childhood in the West Bank, stories of situations that Serry, who grew up in a large American city without being exposed to strife of any kind, had no interest in experiencing firsthand.
所以毫无疑问他们会结婚，毫无疑问他们会共度余生。唯一真正的疑问是去哪里抚养孩子。在这一点上，塞里的态度非常坚决。当他们相互了解时，她的丈夫分享了他在西岸童年的恐怖故事。而塞里在一个从未经历过任何冲突的大型美国城市长大，她对亲身体验那些情景毫无兴趣。
So I convinced him to come to America. And I said it would be a perfect place to raise our children because they would never have to go through some of the things he went through as a child. Anyway, he was very hopeful. He came to this country on a very hopeful note. And we were really happy. We were really happy, very blessed.
所以我说服他来到美国。我说这里将是一个抚养我们孩子的绝佳地方，因为他们永远不必经历他小时候经历过的一些事情。总之，他满怀希望。他带着非常美好的愿景来到这个国家。我们当时真的很快乐，真的很幸福，非常幸运。
The couple started out in New York City, but after having three children, decided that they wanted a more suburban existence, a quiet place where their kids could play outside. Now let me clarify something about Serry and her husband. Though they were personally devout Muslims, they were all about assimilation. In fact, growing up, Serry had almost no Muslim friends. So when it came time to move, they didn't worry much about finding a community where there were people who shared their faith. Instead, they picked a small, prosperous town on the East Coast.
这对夫妇最初住在纽约市，但在有了三个孩子后，决定去郊区生活，找个安静的地方让孩子们可以在户外玩耍。现在我得澄清一下塞里和她丈夫的情况。尽管他们个人是非常虔诚的穆斯林，但他们非常推崇同化。事实上，在成长过程中，塞里几乎没有穆斯林朋友。所以当他们搬家时，并不担心寻找一个有着共同信仰的社区。相反，他们选择了东海岸的一个小型繁荣城镇。
There was no mosque around. The nearest mosque was actually about an hour from where we lived. We went there maybe sporadically. But it was never really an issue because we always thought we were free to practice our religion anywhere we were. And honestly, to me, I think it's very boring if I were just surrounded by Muslims. So I was actually looking forward to raising my children where we landed.
附近没有清真寺。最近的清真寺距离我们住的地方大约要一个小时车程。我们偶尔会去，但那从来都不是什么问题，因为我们一直认为，无论身在何处，我们都有自由实践我们的宗教。说实话，对我来说，如果仅仅被穆斯林包围，我觉得非常无聊。所以我很期待在定居的地方抚养我的孩子。
The family spent four happy years in their new home, had two more children, a successful local business. And then came September 11. Like everyone else, Serry and her husband watched in horror as the towers came down, worried about their friends and family. And then, like most people, went back to their day to day lives. But suddenly, Serry says, her neighbors in her small town seemed to see her in a different way. They didn't return her greetings and stared at her hijab, the headscarf she wore out of respect for God.
一家人在新家度过了快乐的四年，又生了两个孩子，还有一家成功的当地企业。然后“9·11”事件发生了。像其他人一样，塞里和她的丈夫惊恐地看着双子塔倒塌，担心他们的朋友和家人。然后，像大多数人一样，他们回到了日常生活。但突然间，塞里说，她小镇的邻居们似乎用一种不同的眼光看她了。他们不再回馈她的问候，而是盯着她戴的希贾布（头巾），那是她出于对上帝的敬畏而戴的。
I saw it in people. I saw something that wasn't there before. And it was-- sometimes I would drive, and drivers in the next lane would give me the finger.
我在人们眼中看到了它。我看到了一种以前不存在的东西。而且——有时我开车时，隔壁车道的司机对我竖中指。
Serry says she usually flashed the peace sign back, then drove away. But every time this happened, it absolutely floored her. It just didn't conform to her idea of herself.
塞里说她通常会回敬一个和平手势，然后开车离开。但每次发生这种情况时，她都感到彻底崩溃。这完全不符合她对自己的认知。
You mostly saw yourself as American, right?
你大多时候把自己看作美国人，对吧？
Yes, absolutely. I mean that was my primary identifier.
是的，绝对是。我的意思是，那是我的第一身份标识。
Then almost a year after September 11, Serry got a very clear signal that at least one of her neighbors didn't see her as American as she saw herself.
然后在“9·11”事件发生近一年后，塞里收到了一个非常明确的信号，至少有一位邻居并不像她自己认为的那样看她。
I got up in the morning and piled the kids into my minivan only to find out that our minivan had been vandalized. Our windshield was broken, and there was a note that was left on the broken windshield saying-- essentially ordered us to leave the country.
那天早上起床，我把孩子们塞进面包车，却发现面包车被破坏了。挡风玻璃碎了，上面留下一张纸条，基本上命令我们离开这个国家。
Serry immediately hid the note in her purse, and tried to minimize the whole thing for the kids.
塞里立即把纸条藏进钱包，试图在孩子面前淡化整件事。
I told them things would be OK. And I told them not to really talk about it to anyone.
我告诉他们一切都会好的。我告诉他们不要真的和任何人谈论这件事。
Why did you tell them not to tell anybody or talk about it?
你为什么要告诉他们不要告诉任何人或讨论这件事？
Well, I didn't want them bringing attention to themselves that way. As a mother, I just didn't want people to perceive us as victims, as people that this is done to. I was hoping it was just an isolated incident. And so that's what I told the kids. It was probably some maybe adolescent who had a bad day. So we chalked it up to that.
嗯，我不想让他们那样引起对他人的注意。作为母亲，我只是不想让人把我们视为受害者，视为被这样对待的人。我希望这只是个孤立事件。所以这就是我告诉孩子们的原因。可能只是某个心情不好的青少年。所以我们把它归咎于此。
Serry's husband, however, had a different view. Perhaps because of his background, perhaps for some other reason, he found the incident profoundly unsettling. But, like Serry, he minimized the situation in front of the kids.
然而，塞里的丈夫有不同的看法。也许是因为他的背景，也许是出于其他原因，他发现这次事件极其令人不安。但是，像塞里一样，他在孩子面前也尽量淡化这种情况。
He never showed the children that he was upset really. He just told them, these things happen from time to time. Vandalisms happen unfortunately.
他从未向孩子们表现出他真的很难过。他只是告诉他们，这些事情不时会发生。不幸的是，破坏行为时有发生。
And so the family continued as it had. In private, Serry and her husband prayed five times a day. But in the outside world, aside from the hijab Serry wore, they downplayed their faith, rarely talked about it. This was also true of their children.
于是这个家庭像往常一样继续生活。私下里，塞里和她的丈夫每天祈祷五次。但在外部世界，除了塞里戴的头巾外，他们淡化了自己的信仰，很少谈论它。这对他们的孩子来说也是如此。
I really didn't have any Muslim friends.
我真的没有任何穆斯林朋友。
Really?
真的吗？
No.
是的。
This is Serry's twelve year old daughter, her eldest. I'll call her Chloe. Chloe, like her mother, is shockingly beautiful. So it's no surprise to hear that even though she had no Muslim friends, for most of her life Chloe was extremely popular. That's what her mother says, and Chloe agrees.
这是塞里十二岁的女儿，她的大女儿。我就叫她克洛伊吧。克洛伊和她母亲一样，美得惊人。所以听到尽管没有穆斯林朋友，克洛伊一生中大部分时间都非常受欢迎，一点也不奇怪。她母亲是这么说的，克洛伊也同意。
I had a lot of friends. We were into horses basically. And we went over to each other's houses just to play with them, talk about them, and draw them.
我有很多朋友。我们基本上都迷恋马匹。我们去对方家里玩，聊关于马的话题，还画它们。
Because Chloe spent most of her life in the same town, growing up with the same kids, September 11 didn't really affect her relationships. Her friends knew she was Muslim, but clearly didn't care. They still went to each other's houses and played with their toy horses. At least that's how it was for about a year after the towers came down.
因为克洛伊一生大部分时间都在同一个小镇度过，和同样的孩子一起长大，“9·11”并没有真正影响她的人际关系。她的朋友们知道她是穆斯林，但显然不在乎。他们仍然去对方家里玩玩具马。至少双子塔倒塌后的一年里是这样。
Then, Chloe turned nine and entered the fourth grade. Chloe, who had always done well academically, was looking forward to going back to class. She thought it would be a normal school year. And in fact, when Chloe showed up in her classroom at the end of the summer, close to the year anniversary of September 11, things did seem pretty normal.
然后，克洛伊九岁了，上了四年级。一直以来成绩优异的克洛伊很期待重返课堂。她以为那会是正常的一学年。事实上，当克洛伊在暑假结束时出现在教室里，接近“9·11”一周年纪念日时，一切看起来确实挺正常的。
I got to meet my teacher, and she seemed nice the first day, the first week. But it all changed on September 11, that one day.
我见到了我的老师，第一天、第一周她看起来都很好。但这一切在9月11日那天改变了。
I picked up the children from school that day, and she was in tears. She was inconsolable. She wasn't even making sense. She just was crying and crying.
那天我从学校接孩子们回家，她当时泪流满面。她伤心得无法安慰。她的话甚至逻辑不通。她只是不停地哭。
Apparently, as part of the lesson for the 9/11 anniversary, the teacher in Chloe's class had passed out a book, a slim paperback intended to educate the students about the 9/11 tragedy.
显然，作为“9·11”周年纪念课程的一部分，克洛伊班上的老师分发了一本书，一本旨在向学生介绍“9·11”悲剧的薄平装书。
On the cover it was a picture of The World Trade Center in flames.
封面上是一张世贸中心着火的照片。
And the first thing was, September 11 was a horrible day. Thousands and thousands died. And it said, "Who did it? We don't know, but here's a clue."
书里的第一件事就是，“9·11”是可怕的一天。成千上万的人死亡了。接着写道：“是谁干的？我们不知道，但这里有个线索。”
Muslims hate Christians. Muslims hate Americans. Muslims believe that anyone who doesn't practice Islam is evil, and that the Koran teaches war and hate.
穆斯林恨基督徒。穆斯林恨美国人。穆斯林认为任何不信奉伊斯兰教的人都是邪恶的，而《古兰经》教导的是战争和仇恨。
There were three other people sitting at my table. And we were all just looking at the book. And I was glancing at their faces while we were reading it. And some of them-- their eyes started to widen, and they just kind of looked at me every time she said the word Muslim. There were some pictures of Muslim ladies wearing the headscarf, hijab. And some of them said, "Hey, those weird ladies. Her mom is one of them." And then they just all looked at me and said, "You're one of those bad Muslims, aren't you?" And I just said, no, no I'm not.
我们桌旁还坐着三个孩子。我们都在看着那本书。老师读的时候，我一直在观察他们的脸。有些人的眼睛开始瞪大，每当她说到“穆斯林”这个词，他们就盯着我看。书里有一些穆斯林妇女戴着头巾（希贾布）的照片。其中一些孩子说：“嘿，那些奇怪的女人。她的妈妈就是其中之一。”然后他们都看着我说：“你是那些坏穆斯林之一，对吧？”我只是说，不，我不是。
Naturally, after hearing about her daughter's day, Serry called the principal, who was sympathetic but explained to Serry that there just wasn't much she could do.
自然，在听说了女儿一天的遭遇后，塞里给校长打了电话。校长表现得很同情，但向塞里解释说她能做的不多。
It turns out that this was actually a district-wide lesson, meaning that there was a book presented to all the fourth grades in the district.
事实证明，这实际上是一个学区范围内的课程，意味着该学区所有的四年级学生都收到了一本书。
Now you might remember that in America following 9/11, there was an immediate press to construct some narrative about what had happened, a need for an explanation of why and what for. And so, all over the country in hundreds of school districts, educators set to work trying to pull together the few facts they had, assemble them into a plausible argument. Now from Serry's perspective, the version of the narrative presented to her daughter's class was visibly, plainly destructive. But when she confronted Chloe's teacher about the book, the woman didn't seem to agree.
你可能记得在“9·11”之后的美国，迫切需要构建某种关于所发生事件的叙事，迫切需要解释原因和目的。所以，全国成百上千个学区的教育工作者开始尝试汇集他们掌握的有限事实，并将它们整合成一个合理的论点。从塞里的角度来看，呈现给她女儿班级的那个版本明显是破坏性的。但当她就这本书与克洛伊的老师对质时，那个女人似乎并不认同。
The teacher really didn't have any problem with it. She actually shrugged her shoulders and said well, this is the district-wide lesson.
老师对那本书真的没有任何意见。她实际上耸了耸肩，说：嗯，这是学区统一的课程。
At that point, Serry's kids were the only practicing Muslims in the school. There was one other Middle Eastern family, but they were secular, and their children were younger, still in kindergarten. In fact, it was pointed out to Serry by school administrators, she was the only parent of any child in the school who had a problem with the 9/11 materials. And then the matter was pretty much dropped by the administration. But moving on was much more difficult for Chloe and her classmates.
那时，塞里的孩子是学校里唯一的穆斯林教徒。还有另一个中东家庭，但他们是世俗的，而且他们的孩子更小，还在上幼儿园。事实上，学校管理人员曾向塞里指出，她是学校里所有家长中唯一对“9·11”教材有意见的人。随后，校方基本上就不再理会这件事了。但对于克洛伊和她的同学们来说，事情没那么容易翻篇。
They all saw me as a different person. Before reading the book, I was just a normal child. And then, I turned into an Islamic extremist who hated the world and wanted to kill everybody. And there's a big difference there.
他们都把我当成了一个不同的人。读这本书之前，我只是个普通的孩子。然后，我变成了憎恨世界、想要杀光所有人的伊斯兰极端分子。这中间可是有很大区别的。
That's when the taunting began. It was just overnight.
就在那时，嘲笑开始了。几乎是一夜之间。
They called me "loser Muslim" and "Osama." They said he was related to me because my mom looks different and she looks like his people. All my friends were starting to question me nonstop. And they were asking me, why does your mom wear that on her head again? And are you sure you're not related to Osama?
他们叫我“失败的穆斯林”和“奥萨马”。他们说他和我有亲戚关系，因为我妈妈看起来很不一样，看起来像他的人。我所有的朋友都开始没完没了地质问我。他们问我：为什么你妈妈又要戴那个在头上？你确定你和奥萨马没有亲戚关系吗？
It got so bad that when Chloe tried to explain to her best friend that none of this was right, that Muslims weren't bad people who wanted to kill everyone, even her best friend could only reluctantly agree.
情况变得非常糟糕，以至于当克洛伊试图向她最好的朋友解释这一切都是错的，穆斯林并不是想杀光所有人的坏人时，连她最好的朋友也只能勉强同意。
She said, "Well OK, if you say it, then I'll believe you. But it's in a book so it must be true." I didn't want them to think about it anymore. Maybe if I just changed the subject each time they brought it up, I could just move on. If we were in the library, I'll just pick a book and say, have you ever read this book? Let's look at it. Or we would talk about horses. But it didn't really seem to work.
她说：“好吧，既然你这么说，那我就相信你。但书上这么写，那一定是真的。”我不想让他们再想这件事了。也许如果我每次他们提起这个话题时都换个话题，我就能翻篇了。如果我们是在图书馆，我会挑一本书说：你读过这本书吗？让我们看看。或者我们会聊聊马。但这似乎没用。
And so Chloe came up with a different strategy. She decided to renounce her religion. One day that fall, she sat down with her mother and explained that was it all just too much pressure.
于是克洛伊想出了另一种策略。她决定放弃她的宗教。那年秋天的一天，她和母亲坐下来，解释说这一切压力太大了。
I just thought that I can't be Muslim anymore, because then everybody's going to keep bothering me. Everybody is going to make fun of me. And if I had a mom that didn't wear hijab, maybe they would feel that they could be seen with me and have fun with me.
我只是觉得我不能再做穆斯林了，因为那样大家就会一直骚扰我。大家都会取笑我。如果我有一个不戴头巾的妈妈，也许他们会觉得可以跟我一起玩，和我在一起很开心。
Did she seem sad when you told her that you didn't want to be Muslim anymore?
当你告诉她你不想再做穆斯林时，她看起来很难过吗？
Yeah, she seemed very upset.
是的，她看起来非常不安。
Serry was very upset. For her, faith in God was sustaining. It helped her get up in the morning. But given her daughter's difficult time in school, she and the rest of the family decided to make some adjustments.
塞里非常难过。对她来说，对上帝的信仰是一种支撑。它帮助她每天早晨起床。但鉴于女儿在学校的艰难处境，她和家人决定做出一些调整。
We didn't want to force it on her. So in a way, we all kind of stopped practicing the way we did before.
我们不想强迫她。所以从某种意义上说，我们都停止了像以前那样践行信仰。
They did nothing for Ramadan that year. That was one concession. There were others. And in this way, the family stumbled forward. October came and went. November came and went. And then there was December.
那一年他们没有进行任何斋月活动。这是一个让步。还有其他的。就这样，这个家庭步履蹒跚地向前走。十月过去了，十一月过去了，然后就是十二月。
In December, everything went downhill again. December 1, my teacher said, "We're going to be reading a Christmas book every single day. I have a whole collection. I have hundreds of books at home. And we're going to read them every day."
在十二月，一切又急转直下。12月1日，我的老师说：“我们每天都要读一本圣诞书。我家里有整个收藏。我有几百本书。我们每天都要读它们。”
Chloe says the idea of reading a Christmas book every day actually didn't bother her. She did Christmas activities every year, and her family usually went out to celebrate the holiday with one or another of their Christian friends. So Chloe wasn't worried. But then on the fifth day of December, the teacher brought in a book that talked about Jesus' blood, how the blood of God's only son could save you. And to underline her point, she used a visual aid. Here's Serry.
克洛伊说，每天读一本圣诞书的想法其实并不困扰她。她每年都参加圣诞活动，家里通常会和基督徒朋友们一起庆祝这个节日。所以克洛伊并不担心。但到了12月5日，老师带来了一本书，里面讲述了耶稣的血，上帝的独生子的血如何能拯救你。为了强调重点，她使用了教具。这是塞里的话。
Apparently the teacher had held up a candy cane, passed out candy canes to the class and said, "Look children. Let's reflect on the candy cane. It's in the shape of a J for Jesus. And it has red stripes signifying the blood of Jesus."
显然老师举起了一根拐杖糖，发给班上每个学生，说：“看，孩子们。让我们思考一下这根拐杖糖。它的形状是耶稣（Jesus）的第一个字母J。红条纹象征着耶稣的血。”
Then, from her own words, she said, "Jesus' blood will save us all. So as long as you're Christian, you'll be saved and you're fine." And that really upset me a lot. I said, "What if we aren't Christians?" She said, "Well, just believe in Jesus and his blood will save you. Jesus' blood will save you."
然后，用她自己的话说，她说：“耶稣的血会拯救我们所有人。只要你是基督徒，你就会得救，你会没事的。”这真的让我非常难过。我说：“如果我们不是基督徒呢？”她说：“嗯，只要相信耶稣，他的血就会拯救你。耶稣的血会拯救你。”
The kids of course picked up on this as well. And the idea that their classmate would go to hell was quickly incorporated into the daily teasing. But the response of her peers wasn't the real issue anymore. Chloe now had bigger problems. She was afraid that she and her family would burn in hellfire for eternity. Serry says she seemed to become obsessed with this idea.
孩子们当然也听进去了。那个同学会下地狱的想法很快被融入到日常的嘲弄中。但同龄人的反应已不再是真正的问题。克洛伊现在有了更大的麻烦。她害怕她和她的家人会永远在地狱的烈火中燃烧。塞里说她似乎沉迷于这个想法。
"Are we going to go to hell if I don't believe Jesus' blood saves me? Are we going to go to hell?"
“如果我们不相信耶稣的血能拯救我，我们会去地狱吗？我们会去地狱吗？”
How often would she ask you if she was going to go to hell?
她问过你多少次她是否会去地狱？
Well during the last couple weeks of December, it was pretty much-- it was her focus.
嗯，在十二月的最后几周，基本上——这成了她的焦点。
She started to get sick, literally physically ill. She would stay home for days at a time. Serry grew more and more concerned. And so over the December break, she set up a meeting with Chloe's teacher and the school's principal. Apparently, this meeting didn't go very well. Serry says the teacher seemed defensive and ended up leaving abruptly.
她开始生病，真的是身体上的疾病。她有时一连几天待在家里。塞里变得越来越担心。于是在十二月放假期间，她安排了一次与克洛伊老师和校长的会面。显然，这次会面进行得并不顺利。塞里说老师表现得很有防御心，最后匆忙离场。
Now I should say here that I did contact the school to get their side of the story, but they declined to comment because of a pending civil lawsuit. According to Serry, however, the meeting ended on a somewhat promising note. She says she left the school with the distinct impression that the problems between her daughter and her teacher would be addressed. This, however, was not the conclusion presented to Chloe on the morning of her return.
我应该在这里说明一下，我联系了学校想听听他们的说法，但由于涉及民事诉讼，他们拒绝置评。然而根据塞里的说法，会谈是在一个看似有希望的气氛中结束的。她说她离开学校时，有明显的印象认为女儿和老师之间的问题会得到解决。然而，这并不是克洛伊返校那天所见到的结果。
Her teacher approached her in front of the class and said, "You need to transfer to a different classroom. Since you're so uncomfortable, I think you need to transfer to a different classroom." And Chloe said--
老师在全班面前走向她说：“你需要转到另一个教室。既然你这么不舒服，我想你需要转到另一个教室。”克洛伊说——
"But I'd like to stay here because all my friends are here." And she said "No, but I insist. You may go transfer to another classroom."
“但我还是想留在这里，因为我所有的朋友都在这儿。”她说：“不，但我坚持。你可以去转到另一个教室。”
But then some other children in the class called her "loser Muslim." "Get lost, loser Muslim. We don't want you here. Get lost."
然后班上其他一些孩子叫她“失败的穆斯林”。“滚开，失败的穆斯林。我们不欢迎你。滚开。”
And my teacher was just sitting and watching.
而我的老师只是坐在那里看着。
Chloe came home that afternoon and immediately got into bed. She didn't want to go to school the next day, told her mother that she never wanted to go again. But the night after she was told to leave, she got a phone call from one of her friends.
克洛伊那天下午回家后立刻上了床。她第二天不想去学校了，告诉妈妈她再也不想去了。但在她被告知离开的那个晚上，她接到了一个朋友的电话。
Her girlfriend called her and told her she missed her. So that helped her to go to school the next day. But she went into school, and again the kids said "Well why are you here, loser Muslim? The teacher told you to leave. Why are you here?" When she had missed that day before and gone to bed, her teacher had told the class that she was no longer in their class. So when she showed up the next day, the kids wanted to know why she was back. So all through lunch, and then outside at recess, the kids were following her around, telling her she was a loser and they didn't want her in their class.
她的女性朋友给她打电话，说很想念她。所以这帮她第二天去了学校。但她进了学校，孩子们又说：“嗯，你怎么在这儿，失败的穆斯林？老师让你离开。你为什么还在这儿？”在之前缺课的那天，老师告诉全班她不再是这个班的学生了。所以当她第二天出现时，孩子们想知道她为什么又回来了。所以整个午餐时间，以及外面的课间休息时，孩子们都在跟着她转，叫她失败者，说他们不想让她留在班里。
When I picked her up and brought her home, she was still shaking and crying. And nothing, nothing stopped it. No amount of hugs, no amount of comforting helped. And it was so bad the next morning when she got up, the little blood vessels in her face had burst from just sobbing so hard. And she went to bed, and she didn't get out of bed for five days.
当我接她回家时，她还在发抖和哭泣。没有什么，真的没有什么能停下来。无论怎么拥抱，怎么安慰都没有用。第二天早上她起床时，情况更糟了，因为哭得太厉害，她脸上的小血管都爆裂了。她上了床，整整五天没下床。
It was around this time that Serry's husband also began to go downhill. Serry says that for some reason, watching his daughter's torment seemed to undermine his self-confidence in a way she could never have anticipated. It made him feel helpless.
大约也是这个时候，塞里的丈夫也开始陷入低谷。塞里说，由于某种原因，看着女儿遭受的折磨似乎以她从未预料到的方式摧毁了他的自信心。这让他感到无助。
He just didn't know how to handle it. And he became very depressed, severely depressed. I mean I would go and run some errands, and then I would come back and I'd find her in bed and then him on the couch, just staring at the ceiling.
他根本不知道如何处理。他变得非常抑郁，严重的抑郁。我的意思是，我会出去办些琐事，回来时发现她躺在床上，他则躺在沙发上，呆呆地望着天花板。
Serry says her husband had never behaved this way before.
塞里说她的丈夫以前从未有过这种表现。
No, no, never. He was the kind who would walk into the room and people would just start laughing. He had that effect on people. And he changed.
不，不，从未有过。他以前是一个走进房间人们就会开始发笑的人。他就是有那种感染力。而他变了。
I think it did effect him a lot.
我想这确实对他影响很大。
Chloe, like her mother, says she noticed a distinct change in her father during this time. She tells me about one sad day that winter, when her father took her and her sisters to the park.
克洛伊和她母亲一样，说她在那段时间注意到了父亲明显的改变。她告诉我那个冬天里悲伤的一天，当时父亲带她和姐妹们去公园。
And I came up to him and I said, "Dad, you want to come play with us?" He said, "Um, maybe later. I don't feel so good right now." And that just became his answer to everything. He just sat in front of the TV or he went to bed. And I just thought that's not really him.
我走到他跟前说：“爸爸，你想来跟我们一起玩吗？”他说：“嗯，可能过会儿吧。我现在感觉不太好。”那成了他对所有事情的回答。他只是坐在电视机前或者回房睡觉。我当时心想，那真的不是他。
I think it was because of what was happening in school. Because I think when he was younger, he went through the same thing. Because over there in Palestine, the Muslims are having trouble. And I just think he felt bad because I was going through it this time.
我想这是因为学校里发生的事情。因为我想他年轻时经历过同样的事情。因为在巴勒斯坦那边，穆斯林正遭遇困难。我只是觉得他感到很难过，因为这次轮到我经历了。
Because of the strain, Serry and her husband began to fight, long arguments about where they had decided to live and the nature of the country that they had made their home.
由于这种压力，塞里和丈夫开始争吵，关于他们决定住在哪里的长期争论，以及他们安家的这个国家的本质。
He thought it was a mistake that he had come to America. And that was difficult for me to hear, because I was the one who brought him to this country. And I was one who said our kids would never have to deal with anything like he dealt with.
他认为来美国是个错误。这对我来说很难听进去，因为是我带他来到这个国家的。也是我说我们的孩子永远不必面对他所经历过的任何事情。
And so did you try to convince him, no this isn't really what America is like?
那么你有没有试着说服他，不，这不是美国真实的样子？
Yeah, but it was really difficult to tell him that, when the reality was-- I mean our children, and it wasn't just Chloe anymore. It was even my other girls.
是的，但当事实摆在眼前时，真的很难告诉他——我的意思是我们的孩子们，而且不仅仅是克洛伊了。甚至是我的其他女儿们。
Chloe's sister, [? Samia, ?] was punched in the face by the younger brother of one of Chloe's main tormentors. Then Serry's other daughter admitted that the boys at school had been harassing her. Every day or so after lunch, they would surround her on the playground.
克洛伊的妹妹被克洛伊的主要嘲弄者之一的弟弟打了一拳。然后塞里的另一个女儿承认学校里的男孩一直在骚扰她。每天午餐后，他们都会在操场上围住她。
They would all point at her and make a motion of unzipping their pants and say, "We're all going to pee on her. Let's all pee on her."
他们全都指着她，做着解开裤子的动作说：“我们要一起朝她撒尿。咱们一起朝她撒尿吧。”
But the last straw, as far as Chloe was concerned, happened sometime in late March, the day after she had been transferred against her will to a new classroom. Walking down the hall, she spied the girl who had been her best friend in her old class, probably the only girl who had really stuck by her through all her trouble. But when Chloe waved, the girl didn't respond.
但据克洛伊所知，最后一根稻草发生在三月下旬的某个时候，就在她违背意愿被转到新班级的第二天。走廊里，她瞥见了那个曾经是她旧班级里最好的朋友的女孩，可能是唯一一个在所有麻烦中一直支持她的女孩。但当克洛伊挥手时，那个女孩没有回应。
I was just kind of thinking maybe she just didn't see me and hear me. But then when I went to lunch, I said hi again. And I went in front of her and I said hi. And she turned her head. And that's when I knew. Everybody has turned against me. I dropped out from there. I stayed home for a long time.
我当时心想也许她只是没看见我，没听见我。但午餐时，我又说了一次嗨。我走到她面前说嗨。她扭过了头。那一刻我知道了。所有人都反对我。我从那以后就退学了。我在家待了很长时间。
For the rest of her fourth grade year, Chloe was tutored. The school found someone to come twice a week. Now I should say that while I was not able to speak to the school about what happened, the US Department of Justice, which eventually got involved in this case, was able to confirm the broad outlines of Chloe and Serry's story, including that the teacher behaved inappropriately by proselytizing during class time in a public school, and that the teacher's behavior towards Chloe contributed to an atmosphere in which Chloe was harassed by her peers.
四年级的剩余时间，克洛伊接受了辅导。学校找人每周来两次。我应该说明，虽然我无法与学校谈论发生的事情，但美国司法部最终介入了此案，确认了克洛伊和塞里故事的大致轮廓，包括老师在公立学校教学期间传教是不当行为，且老师对克洛伊的态度导致了克洛伊受到同伴骚扰的氛围。
The man that I spoke to at the Justice Department was Eric Treene who supervises cases of religious discrimination. He told me that Justice first learned about Chloe's case during one of the post 9/11 get-togethers that the department now holds with a variety of Muslim groups.
我在司法部联系的那个人是主管宗教歧视案件的埃里克·特林。他告诉我，司法部是在“9·11”之后他们现在与各种穆斯林团体举行的聚会中首次了解到克洛伊案件的。
At one of these meetings, a woman from a Muslim women's group brought up this case and said, well is this the type of case you might be able to do anything about? And we said, well yes. We thoroughly investigated the situation. We believed that certain action, remedial action, was merited here. And we reached an agreement with the school district requiring such remedial action.
在这些会议中的一次，一位穆斯林妇女团体的女士提出了这个案例，并问：这是你们可能采取行动处理的案例吗？我们说，是的。我们对情况进行了彻底调查。我们认为这里需要采取补救措施。我们与学区达成了要求采取此类补救措施的协议。
In other words, the school district ended up settling the Justice Department's claims against them. Now because there was a settlement, the Justice Department can't discuss the details of the case. Can't tell us, for example, which of the allegations made by Serry and Chloe they were able to verify. Treene, however, was able to say this about what the school ultimately agreed to.
换句话说，学区最终与司法部达成了和解。由于存在和解协议，司法部不能讨论案件细节。不能告诉我们，例如，塞里和克洛伊提出的指控中哪些是他们能够证实的。不过，特林能够说出学校最终同意了什么。
All teachers would receive diversity training, as would all students. And then there would be, for this particular teacher, specific performance goals that had to be met and oversight. And they needed to report to us on both the general program of diversity training, as well as the goals set forth for this particular teacher.
所有老师都将接受多样性培训，所有学生也一样。此外，对于这位特定老师，会有需要达成的特定表现目标和监督措施。他们需要向我们报告通用的多样性培训计划，以及为这位特定老师设定的目标。
That agreement was reached in March of 2005. But according to Serry, by that time it was too late, way too late. See, during the summer after Chloe's fourth grade year, Serry and her husband decided to transfer all their kids to a different school. She says they wanted to start again. They met with district administrators and asked for a placement in a school where their kids would know that they were safe.
该协议于2005年3月达成。但根据塞里的说法，那时已经太晚了，太晚了。你看，在克洛伊四年级后的那个夏天，塞里和丈夫决定把所有孩子转到另一所学校。她说他们想重新开始。他们会见学区管理人员，要求安排一所孩子们会知道他们是安全的学校。
But in late summer, the district people said that they couldn't offer any absolute assurances that the children wouldn't face harassment. And as far as Serry was concerned, that meant just one thing. The family would have to move. She couldn't take another year of turmoil.
但在夏末，学区的人说他们不能提供任何绝对的保证，孩子们不会遭受骚扰。对塞里而言，这意味着只有一件事。这个家庭必须搬走。她无法再忍受一年的动荡。
So over a few weeks' time, we literally packed up, and we pretty much were forced to leave.
所以几周之内，我们真正打包好，基本上被强迫离开了。
Serry remembers sitting down with her husband to try to figure out whether the family should move east, west, north or south. But her husband had a very different idea.
塞里记得和丈夫坐下来试图弄清楚这个家庭应该往东、往西、往北还是往南走。但她的丈夫有完全不同的想法。
When it came time for us to move from where we were, he wanted to leave the country, which I couldn't fathom. And so he wound up leaving us. He wound up just walking out one day.
当我们要搬离住处时，他想离开这个国家，我无法理解。最后他离开我们了。他有一天就那样走掉了。
Serry naturally was devastated. She loved her husband. She loves her husband. But she didn't want to move back to the West Bank, and that was the place her husband yearned to go. He argued that at least everyone in the West Bank had the same problem, was in the same boat. And for him, that made the difficulties bearable. In America, he said, you face the same troubles, but you face them alone. Serry didn't see things that way at all. She says that because she grew up in this country, she just had a more subtle reading of what had happened to her family.
塞里自然心碎了。她爱她的丈夫，她爱着他。但她不想搬回西岸，那是她丈夫渴望去的地方。他辩称，至少在西岸，每个人都有同样的问题，都在同一条船上。对他来说，这让困难变得可以忍受。他说，在美国，你面临同样的麻烦，但你是独自一人面对。塞里一点也不这样看。她说因为她是在这个国家长大的，所以她对家里发生的事情有更微妙的解读。
In other words-- well I was born and raised in this country, and I'm aware of what makes this country great, and I know that what happened to our family, it doesn't speak to American values. And I feel like this is such a fluke. I have to believe this is not what America is about. I know that. But I don't think that's the same for my husband. I think he came to this country with certain hopes and dreams, and it was pretty much a big letdown.
换句话说——嗯，我是在这个国家出生长大的，我了解是什么让这个国家伟大，我知道发生在我们家身上的事情，并不代表美国的价值观。我觉得这只是个意外。我必须相信这不是美国的本来面目。我知道这一点。但我不认为我丈夫也是这么想的。我想他带着某些希望和梦想来到这个国家，结果却是个巨大的失望。
Today, Serry lives alone with her five children in a small apartment about an hour away from her old town. Instead of being a full time mom, as she was for over a decade, she has two jobs and goes to school at night. This means that she rarely sees her children. To keep up with their lives, she has built a mailbox for the kitchen counter. She asks her kids to write her letters about their lives, what happened to them during the day, week. And then, late at night after they've gone to sleep, she sits alone in her bed and reads them. She says that when they don't make her cry, they make her laugh.
今天，塞里独自带着五个孩子住在一个离老镇约一小时路程的小公寓里。她不再是十多年来的全职母亲，而是做了两份工作，晚上还要上学。这意味着她很少见到孩子们。为了跟上他们的生活，她在厨房柜台上做了一个信箱。她要求孩子们给她写关于他们生活的信，告诉她白天、一周里发生了什么。然后，在深夜他们睡着后，她独自坐在床上阅读这些信。她说，当它们不让她流泪时，就会让她欢笑。
It's been almost a year since her husband walked out, went to live with a cousin in a distant state while the family tries to figure out what to do. Serry says that every night she prays for him to come back to her, but they only talks sporadically. Still, she hasn't changed her feelings about moving to the West Bank or her interpretation of what happened to her children and family.
丈夫离开已经快一年了，他搬去了一个遥远的州的表亲那里住，而家里人正试图弄清楚该怎么办。塞里说她每天晚上祈祷他能回来，但他们只是偶尔交谈。不过，她对搬往西岸的想法或对孩子和家人所发生之事的解读并没有改变。
I have to believe this was a fluke. I have to. Otherwise, it's really hard to keep moving forward. But I also think it's a sign of our times. It's happening all across America. It's not just happening in our little town here. We hear stories of different things going on in schools, and places of employment, and public places, in restaurants.
我必须相信这是一个意外。我必须相信。否则，真的很难继续前行。但我也认为这是我们这个时代的迹象。它正在全美范围内发生。不仅仅发生在我们这个小镇。我们听到在学校、工作场所、公共场所、餐馆里发生各种各样的故事。
From his post at the Justice Department, Eric Treene, in his own way, has seen the same thing.
从他在司法部的职位来看，埃里克·特林以他自己的方式看到了同样的情况。
There's been a dramatic rise in hate crimes since 9/11 against Muslims, Arabs, Sikhs, who are often mistaken as being Muslim, and South Asians. And sometimes people with dark skin, such as a Portuguese man, just because they're perceived to be Arab or Muslim.
自“9·11”以来，针对穆斯林、阿拉伯人、经常被误认为是穆斯林的锡克教徒以及南亚人的仇恨犯罪急剧增加。有时是深肤色的人，比如一个葡萄牙男人，仅仅因为被认为是阿拉伯人或穆斯林。
In fact, says Treene, since 9/11, one in five of the complaints reviewed by the Equal Employment Opportunity Commission involves a case of discrimination against Muslims. That number, one in five, is of course totally out of proportion to the number of Muslims that live in America.
事实上，特林说，自“9·11”以来，平等就业机会委员会审查的五分之一投诉涉及针对穆斯林的歧视案件。五分之一这个数字，当然与居住在美国的穆斯林数量完全不成比例。
As for Chloe, she's now happy in her new school, and so far hasn't encountered any problems. She's even gone back to being Muslim.
至于克洛伊，她在新学校过得很开心，到目前为止没有遇到任何问题。她甚至重新成为了穆斯林。
I pray and occasionally will go to the mosque and everything. And we celebrated Ramadan.
我祈祷，偶尔会去清真寺什么的。我们庆祝了斋月。
And how did that feel?
那种感觉如何？
It felt good.
感觉很好。
But, she says, she never acknowledges her religion to her new friends, or really to anyone at her new school. It just wouldn't be a good idea, she tells me.
但是，她说，她从不向新朋友承认自己的宗教信仰，或者在新学校里不向任何人承认。她告诉我，那不是个好主意。
We're still going through war and everything, and it's just so a bad time.
我们还在经历战争什么的，现在是个很糟糕的时期。
Alix Spiegel in Washington, DC. Coming up, now a quick word from our friendly sponsor, who happens to be the world's only superpower. How to explain America in 30 seconds on television to people far, far away. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
华盛顿特区的阿利克斯·斯皮格尔。接下来，从我们友好的赞助商那里听到一句话，碰巧是世界上唯一的超级大国。如何在电视上用30秒向远方的人们解释美国。一分钟后继续收听来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目。
It's This American Life from Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Shouting Across the Divide, stories of Muslims and non-Muslims trying to communicate with each other, and running into some difficulty sometimes doing that. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, America the Ad Campaign.
我是艾拉·格拉斯带来的《美国生活》。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为你带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《隔着鸿沟大声疾呼》，讲述穆斯林和非穆斯林试图相互沟通，有时在沟通中遇到一些困难的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，美国广告活动。
Not long after September 11, as the United States started to fight the Taliban in Afghanistan, there came to be a great interest in this country in bolstering America's image abroad among people who did not seem to see us the way that we see ourselves. We wanted to change that. And one man who got swept up in that effort was one of our regular contributors here at our radio show, Shalom Auslander. Here he is.
“9·11”后不久，随着美国开始在阿富汗打击塔利班，这个国家对提升美国在海外的形象产生了巨大的兴趣，特别是在那些似乎并没有像我们看待自己那样看待我们的人群中。我们想改变这种状况。而其中一个被卷入这项努力的人，是我们电台的一位常客贡献者，沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。他来了。
I worked for an advertising agency in New York City. A major soft drink company needed some commercials for the urban youth market. This meant black kids. They wanted a magic liquid campaign. This meant that someone in the commercial would drink the soda and become magically transformed. The unhappy would become happy. The stupid would become smart. The unpopular would become beloved. I showed them some commercials a week later.
我在纽约的一家广告公司工作。一家大型软饮料公司需要一些针对城市青年市场的广告。这意味着黑人孩子。他们想要一个“魔法液体”活动。这意味着商业广告中有人喝了苏打水，就会神奇地蜕变。不快乐的人会变得快乐。愚蠢的人会变得聪明。不受欢迎的人会变得深受喜爱。一周后我给他们看了些广告。
One commercial took place at a swimming pool where the kids were unhappy. Then they drank the soda. Then they were happy. A long, uncomfortable silence filled the room. Finally, the chief creative director spoke. "Do black kids swim?" he asked. A long debate followed. I hated my job.
其中一个广告发生在游泳池，孩子们很不开心。然后他们喝了苏打水。接着他们就开心了。房间里陷入了一阵漫长、尴尬的沉默。最后，首席创意总监说话了。“黑人孩子游泳吗？”他问。随后发生了一场旷日持久的辩论。我讨厌我的工作。
Three months after 9/11, a meeting was held in the chief creative director's office. America had an image problem in the Muslim world, and the State Department had asked a number of advertising agencies to help fix it. Our agency was one of them. "It wasn't just a chance to help the country," said the chief creative director, "it was a chance to help earn some positive PR for the agency by doing something good." As he spoke the word good, he made quotation marks in the air with his fingers.
“9·11”后三个月，首席创意总监办公室举行了一次会议。美国在穆斯林世界有形象问题，国务院要求多家广告公司帮助修复它。我们公司就是其中之一。“这不仅是一个帮助国家的机会，”首席创意总监说，“这也是通过做一些好事，为公司赢得一些正面公关的机会。”当他说到“好事”这个词时，他的手指在空中比出了引号。
Nobody wanted to work on it. There were a half dozen senior creative directors below the chief creative director, each of whom was responsible for his or her own accounts. Their job performance, salaries, and raises were evaluated in terms of how much money their accounts made or lost over the course of the year. "I don't have time for this pro bono crap," said one. "I mean, I'd love to help, but my software client is up my wazoo with a pitch fork." Others nodded. "Are they doing TV?" asked one. "It's possible," said the chief creative director, "but it won't run in this country." Everyone groaned. If the ads didn't air on American television, then they weren't eligible for American advertising awards shows.
没人想做这个。首席创意总监手下有六名资深创意总监，每人负责自己的客户。他们的工作表现、薪水和加薪都根据他们年度带来的收益或损失来评估。“我没时间处理这些公益垃圾，”其中一个人说。“我的意思是，我很想帮忙，但我的软件客户正拿着干草叉逼我呢。”其他人点头。“他们在做电视广告吗？”一个人问。“有可能，”首席创意总监说，“但它不会在这个国家播出。”大家都呻吟起来。如果广告不在美国电视上播出，那么它们就没资格参加美国广告奖评选。
Most of the creative directors bailed. I was a freelancer at the time, a hired gun. I worked on whatever they told me to work on. The briefing would be later that afternoon. The chief creative director followed me out the door. "Don't let this interfere with the soda account," he said. "We really have to nail that."
大多数创意总监都退出了。那时我是个自由职业者，一个雇佣兵。他们让我做什么我就做什么。简报会在当天晚些时候举行。首席创意总监跟着我走出门口。“别让这事干扰了苏打水客户，”他说。“我们真的必须拿下它。”
I decided to get some lunch. A message was waiting for me when I returned. The account director on Project Dialogue had phoned. That was the code name for the brand America account, Project Dialogue. I phoned her back. "Do you need an Arab?" she asked. "Hello?" "Do you need an Arab?" "I don't need an Arab." "OK" "Thanks though." "If you need one, let me know. We can get you one." "I'm good."
我决定去吃午饭。回来时有一条消息在等我。项目对话的客户主管打过电话。那是“美国品牌”账户的代号，项目对话。我给她回了电话。“你需要一个阿拉伯人吗？”她问。“喂？”“你需要一个阿拉伯人吗？”“我不需要阿拉伯人。”“好的。”“谢谢，不过不用了。”“如果你需要的话，告诉我。我们可以给你找一个。”“不用了，谢谢。”
I took a bite of my chicken sandwich, and flipped through the newspapers and magazines that had collected on my desk. Advertizing Age had a cover story on why it's so hard to cram the benefits of brand USA into a 30-second spot and what might work. They had interviewed famous creative directors across the nation. "You have to infiltrate their lives," said one. "You set up events. You show them movies." He suggested Boogie Nights.
我咬了一口鸡肉三明治，翻阅着桌上堆积的报纸和杂志。《广告时代》封面上有一个故事，讲述了将“美国品牌”的好处浓缩进30秒的短片是多么困难，以及什么可能有效。他们采访了全国著名的创意总监。“你必须渗透进他们的生活，”其中一人说。“你建立活动，给他们看电影。”他建议《不羁夜》。
The Project Dialogue briefing was supposed to begin at 3:00, but trouble on an international cosmetics account pushed it back to 4:00. And news of a possible fast-food pitch pushed it back again until 5:00. Finally, at 5:45, the creative director arrived. He glanced at his watch. "Christ almighty," he said. "Let's get this over with."
项目对话的简报本应在3:00开始，但一个国际化妆品客户出的难题把它推迟到了4:00。快餐业的消息又把它推迟到了5:00。终于，在5:45，创意总监到了。他看了一眼手表。“我的上帝，”他说。“快把它解决掉吧。”
The lights dimmed and the Powerpoint presentation began. As with any other target audience, Muslims had been divided into a few different groups. Likely to agree, the moderate Muslims. Unlikely to agree, the radical Muslims. And the undecideds. A red arrow appeared beside the word "undecideds" and began to flash. "This," said the strategic planner, "is our sweet spot."
灯光变暗，Powerpoint演示开始了。和其他目标受众一样，穆斯林被分成了几个不同的群体。可能同意的，温和派穆斯林。不太可能同意的，激进派穆斯林。还有摇摆不定的。红色的箭头出现在“摇摆不定”这个词旁边，开始闪烁。“这个，”战略规划员说，“是我们的目标核心。”
A few slides later, the undecideds were further broken down into three more subgroups. The hero worshipers, the economic hopefuls, and the future seekers, each of which was divided again into another three groups, all nine of which would require their own distinct form of messaging. "What's the message?" someone asked. "We don't know," answered the strategic planner. "Do they like humor?" someone asked. "We don't know." "Do they trust commercials?" "We don't know." "Are there any commercials they do like?" "We don't know?" "Is a direct approach the best?" "No." "How will they react to an indirect approach?" "Badly."
几张幻灯片之后，“摇摆不定”被进一步分成了三个子群体。崇拜英雄的，经济上怀有希望的，以及未来追求者，每个子群体又被分成了另外三个组，这九个组都需要各自不同的信息传递。“信息是什么？”有人问。“我们不知道，”战略规划员回答。“他们喜欢幽默吗？”有人问。“我们不知道。”“他们信任广告吗？”“我们不知道。”“有他们喜欢的广告吗？”“我们不知道。”“直接的方法最好吗？”“不。”“他们对间接方法会有什么反应？”“糟糕。”
For a group of people setting out to convince another group of people how much we had in common, we didn't seem to know the first thing about them. And I was no exception. The only footage I had ever seen of Afghanistan was of madrassas. Row after row of children rocking back and forth reciting passages loudly from the Koran, a sight so eerily similar to the childhood I'd spent locked up like a veal in an orthodox Jewish yeshiva that I wanted to bomb the place myself.
对于一群试图说服另一群人我们有多少共同点的人来说，我们似乎对他们一无所知。我也不例外。我见过的唯一关于阿富汗的镜头就是宗教学校。一排排孩子前后摇晃，大声朗诵《古兰经》片段，这一景象与我在正统犹太教学校里像小牛一样被关着的童年太相似了，以至于我甚至想亲自炸掉那个地方。
The strategic planner told us that basic messaging concepts were still being tested in focus groups in Egypt and Jordan. And we wouldn't have the final strategy until the following afternoon. The basic function, though, of all communications would be to convince the Muslim world that we all wanted a better life, and that freedom and democracy were the best ways of achieving those desires. I realized that if you switched freedom and democracy with cool and refreshing, it was pretty much the same strategy as the one I'd been given for selling soda to African American kids. But I thought it might be best to bring this up after the meeting.
战略规划员告诉我们，基本信息概念仍在埃及和约旦的焦点小组中进行测试。我们直到第二天下午才能拿到最终策略。不过，所有沟通的基本功能都是要说服穆斯林世界，我们都想要更好的生活，而自由和民主是实现这些愿望的最佳途径。我意识到，如果你把“自由和民主”换成“酷炫和清爽”，这基本上和我之前接到的向非裔美国孩子推销苏打水的策略是一模一样的。但我想最好在会议结束后再提出来。
"So what do you think?" the creative director asked me after the meeting. "I think it's the same strategy as the soda account." "How is that going?" he asked. "Good," I said. "I've been thinking. What if we change it from a swimming pool to a picnic." He thought about that for a moment before frowning and shaking his head. "No good?" I asked. He continued shaking his head. "Black kids don't have picnics?" I asked. "More urban," he said, "you know, like fire hydrants." "Fire hydrants?" "Yeah," he said "you know, when they open the fire hydrants. When it's hot." "Sure," I said. "When it's hot."
“那你怎么看？”会议结束后创意总监问我。“我觉得这和苏打水账户的策略是一样的。”“进展如何？”他问。“不错，”我说。“我一直在想。如果我们把游泳池换成野餐怎么样。”他想了一会儿，然后皱起眉头摇了摇头。“不好吗？”我问。他继续摇头。“黑人孩子不野餐吗？”我问。“更城市化一些，”他说，“你知道，比如消火栓。”“消火栓？”“是啊，”他说，“你知道，当他们打开消火栓时。天热的时候。”“当然，”我说。“天热的时候。”
I assumed we would cut before the cops came and started beating the kids with their night sticks. He nodded, growing increasingly pleased with his idea. "I like that," he said. "A bunch of kids in their bathing suits, jumping around a fire hydrant. We'll get somebody good to direct it. That could be nice, don't you think?" I nodded. "Do black kids have bathing suits?" I asked. "I mean, if they don't swim?" "I like that," he ignored me. "I like that a lot. "Write a few more like that, will you?" "Sure," I said. "How's Friday?" "How's tomorrow?" he asked. "Tomorrow," I said, "no problem."
我假设我们会赶在警察到来，开始用警棍殴打孩子之前剪掉镜头。他点点头，对自己这个想法越来越满意。“我喜欢那个，”他说。“一群穿着泳衣的孩子，围着消火栓跳来跳去。我们会找个好导演来拍。那可能很不错，你不觉得吗？”我点点头。“黑人孩子有泳衣吗？”我问。“我的意思是，如果他们不游泳的话？”“我喜欢那个，”他没理我。“我非常喜欢。多写几个那样的，好吗？”“当然，”我说。“周五怎么样？”“明天怎么样？”他问。“明天，”我说，“没问题。”
The following morning I was sitting in my office writing commercials about black kids and fire hydrants when there was a knock on my door. I looked up to see a man roughly my age with dark skin, slicked back hair, and a drawing pad. "Shalom?" he asked. "I'm Sabhi." I rose and shook his hand. "You must be the Arab," I said. "I'm the Jew."
第二天早上，我坐在办公室写关于黑人小孩和消火栓的广告，有人敲门。我抬头看到一个和我年龄差不多大、深色皮肤、头发抹了发胶、拿着画板的男人。“沙洛姆？”他问。“我是萨比。”我起身和他握手。“你一定是那个阿拉伯人，”我说。“我是犹太人。”
Sabhi was from Lebanon where he had studied graphic arts at the University of Beirut. I asked him what life was like there, how people felt about America, how they felt about their lives and their future. He told me there was a lot of anger and a lot of frustration. There were economic problems, governmental problems, social problems. I asked him what the cause of the problems might be. He told me it was the Jews.
萨比来自黎巴嫩，他在贝鲁特大学学习过图形艺术。我问他那里的生活是什么样，人们对美国有什么感觉，对他们的生活和未来有什么感觉。他告诉我那里有很多愤怒和挫败感。存在经济问题、政府问题、社会问题。我问他问题的原因可能是什么。他告诉我，是犹太人。
"The Jews?" I asked. "The Israelis," he said. He explained that according to Islamic legend, the prophet Mohammed said they would never be peace in the Muslim world until three cities were under Muslim rule. They currently had Mecca and Medina, but Jerusalem was still controlled by the Jews. "The Jews?" I asked. "The Israelis," he said. "And so," he added, "that's why there can be no peace for Muslims."
“犹太人？”我问。“以色列人，”他说。他解释说根据伊斯兰传说，穆罕默德先知曾说，除非三个城市处于穆斯林统治下，否则穆斯林世界永远不会有和平。他们目前拥有麦加和麦地那，但耶路撒冷仍由犹太人控制。“犹太人？”我问。“以色列人，”他说。“所以，”他补充道，“这就是为什么穆斯林不可能有和平。”
An awkward silence followed and an unexpected disappointment overcame me. I realize that as naive as it might have been to think that advertising could solve these century-old problems, a small part of me, and a large part of the US government, hoped that it could. That something, anything, might be said or filmed or edited into a 30-second TV commercial that would undo all that had been so horribly done, and that would avoid all the bad that seemed so certain to come in the future.
尴尬的沉默随之而来，一股意想不到的失望感淹没了我。我意识到，尽管认为广告能解决这些百年老问题可能是天真的，但我的一小部分，以及美国政府的很大一部分，都希望它能成功。希望有什么东西、任何东西能被说出来、拍摄出来，或者剪辑成30秒的电视广告，能扭转所有已经发生的糟糕事情，并且能避免未来似乎必然会发生的坏事。
Unfortunately, I was raised with orthodox religion. And the minute I hear people talking about prophets and holy cities, I lose all hope. That, combined with yesterday's discussion about whether black people swim, and if they do, whether or not they own bathing suits, had caused me to wonder whether we could ever understand the person living right beside us, let alone people on the other side of the world.
不幸的是，我是在正统宗教环境下长大的。每当我听到人们谈论先知和圣城，我就失去了所有希望。再加上昨天关于黑人是否游泳，如果游泳是否拥有泳衣的讨论，导致我怀疑我们是否能真正了解身边生活的人，更不用说世界另一端的人了。
"Well, you've got Mecca and Medina," I offered Sabhi. "Two out of three isn't bad." He kind of laughed. I kind of laughed back. Then he left. The telephone rang. "How did it go?" asked the account director. "Fine," I said. "Was it helpful?" "Very," I said. "Should I get you another one?" she asked.
“嗯，你们拥有麦加和麦地那，”我向萨比建议。“三个里面有两个也不错。”他笑了。我也跟着笑了。然后他走了。电话响了。“怎么样？”客户主管问。“挺好，”我说。“有帮助吗？”“非常有，”我说。“要我再给你找一个吗？”她问。
The focus groups in Jordan and Egypt had not been very helpful. The moderator had shown a number of different boards to a number of different Arab men ages 18 to 34. The first board read, "Children deserve a happy future. And in order to have a happy future, people must be free." "Do you agree with this statement?" asked the moderator. Everyone nodded. "But we don't have freedom," said one, "because of Israel." Everyone nodded.
约旦和埃及的焦点小组并没有什么帮助。主持人向一批18到34岁的阿拉伯男性展示了几个不同的广告板。第一个板子上写着：“孩子值得拥有一个幸福的未来。为了拥有幸福的未来，人们必须自由。”“你们同意这个说法吗？”主持人问。大家都点头。“但我们没有自由，”一个人说，“因为以色列。”大家都点头。
The moderator held up a second board. "We all deserve happiness," read the board, "and part of happiness is having the freedom to pursue your business and economic dreams." Everyone nodded. "We could pursue our economic dreams," said one, "if it weren't for Israel." This continued for some time. It continued with women age 18 to 34. It continued with men age 35 to 50. It continued with women age 35 to 50.
主持人举起第二个板子。“我们都应该拥有幸福，”板子上写着，“幸福的一部分就是有追求商业和经济梦想的自由。”大家都点头。“我们可以追求我们的经济梦想，”一个人说，“如果不是因为以色列的话。”这持续了一段时间。对18到34岁的女性也这样。对35到50岁的男性也这样。对35到50岁的女性也这样。
"Were they all like that?" I asked the strategic planner. He nodded. "What are you going to do?" I asked. "Get off this goddamn assignment," he said.
“他们都那样吗？”我问战略规划员。他点点头。“你打算怎么办？”我问。“退出这个该死的任务，”他说。
There was a four o'clock meeting later that afternoon for me to present my new soda commercials. I made my way to the creative director's office a few minutes early and asked if I could speak with him. "I can't work on this America thing," I told him. "Why not?" he asked. "Did you come up with anything?" "I've got a slogan," I told him. "Two out of three ain't bad. It's about the holy cities."
那天下午四点有个会议，我需要演示我的新苏打水广告。我提前几分钟赶到创意总监的办公室，问能不能跟他谈谈。“我不能再做这个美国项目了，”我告诉他。“为什么不？”他问。“你想到什么了吗？”“我有个口号，”我告诉他。“三个里有两个不错。是关于圣城的。”
On the television behind his desk, Geraldo Rivera was reporting from Tora Bora. "We want Osama bin Laden behind bars," said Geraldo. "Or six feet under. Or maybe just one foot under. Or maybe just a pile of ash." They cut back to Laurie Dhue in the studio. "Well said Geraldo," said Laurie Dhue. The creative director sighed and shook his head. "It's hopeless, isn't it?" he said. "Mankind?" I asked. "Yes," I said, "it is."
在他桌后的电视机里，杰拉尔多·里维拉正在托拉博拉进行报道。“我们要奥萨马·本·拉登被关进监狱，”杰拉尔多说。“或者入土六英尺。或者也许只是一英尺深。或者只是一堆灰烬。”他们切回演播室的劳里·杜。“说得好，杰拉尔多，”劳里·杜说。创意总监叹了口气，摇了摇头。“没救了，对吧？”他说。“人类？”我问。“是的，”我说，“确实没救了。”
We went into the conference room and I presented my black kids around a fire hydrant commercial. For the next 20 minutes, 15 Caucasian people sat around a long, oak table discussing whether or not fire hydrants were racist. And if they weren't, would black kids have bathing suits, given that they don't swim?
我们走进会议室，我演示了我的黑人小孩围着消火栓的广告。接下来的20分钟里，15个白人坐在长长的橡木桌旁讨论消火栓是否种族主义。如果不是，考虑到他们不游泳，黑人孩子会有泳衣吗？
I still hated my job, but at least I was off the America thing. Within a few months, everyone was off it. After dozens of focus groups and tens of thousands of dollars, the only conclusion anyone could reach regarding the question of how to speak to Muslims was that nobody had any idea how to speak to Muslims.
我依然讨厌我的工作，但至少我不用再做美国项目了。几个月内，每个人都退出了。在数十个焦点小组和数万美元之后，关于如何与穆斯林对话的问题，唯一的结论就是：没人知道该怎么跟穆斯林对话。
It wasn't long before the department within the State Department that had been charged with this assignment was dismantled. A few projects survived. Some radio stations were jammed. Some leaflets were dropped. Then Iraq was invaded. Then Shiites began killing Sunnis. Then Sunnis began killing Shiites.
没过多久，负责这项任务的国务院部门就被解散了。一些项目留存了下来。一些广播电台被干扰。一些传单被撒下。然后伊拉克被入侵。然后什叶派开始杀害逊尼派。然后逊尼派开始杀害什叶派。
Maybe it was naive, but five years ago when all this was happening, someone said, let's talk to Muslims. Lately, more and more people are saying, let's not. Let's let Iran talk to them. Let's let Syria talk to them. Let's let the Muslims talk to themselves.
也许那是天真的，但五年前当所有这些发生时，有人说，让我们和穆斯林谈谈。最近，越来越多的人说，不要。让伊朗和他们谈。让叙利亚和他们谈。让穆斯林自己和自己谈。
My fire hydrant commercials never ran either. In the end, it was felt that the fire hydrants might be perceived as racist. And they were replaced in the script with swimming pools and diving boards, scripts a moderator then showed to a roomful of African Americans age 16 to 21.
我的消火栓广告也从来没播过。最终，人们觉得消火栓可能会被认为有种族歧视嫌疑。脚本里的它们被替换成了游泳池和跳板，这些脚本随后被主持人展示给了一群16到21岁的非裔美国人。
"Do you like these commercials?" the moderator asked. Everyone frowned. "Black kids don't swim," said the African Americans age 16 to 21. Someone suggested the location should be more urban, a city perhaps, maybe a fire hydrant. The moderator nodded. A few weeks later, the project was reassigned to an African American agency. It was thought best that they talked to themselves.
“你们喜欢这些广告吗？”主持人问。大家都皱起了眉头。“黑人孩子不游泳，”16到21岁的非裔美国人说。有人建议地点应该更城市化一些，也许是一个城市，或者一个消火栓。主持人点点头。几周后，这个项目被重新分配给了一家非裔美国人代理机构。人们认为让他们自己跟自己谈是最好的。
Shalom Auslander. He's the author of a book of short stories called Beware of God. A new book about his own very strict religious upbringing comes out next year.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。他是短篇小说集《当心上帝》的作者。一本关于他自己非常严格的宗教成长经历的新书明年就会出版。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Cathy Hoang. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、戴安·库克、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·柯尼希、丽莎·波拉克和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。塞思·林德和凯茜·黄提供了制作协助。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. You know he just invited me to his house party for the weekend.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，他刚刚邀请我去参加他周末的家庭聚会。
A bunch of kids in their bathing suits, jumping around a fire hydrant. That could be nice, don't you think?
一群穿着泳衣的孩子，围着消火栓跳来跳去。那可能很不错，你不觉得吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。